this one is on the analemma I know her
very well she is she's not the best
person in the world I'm sorry I anma
isn't oh that's sad that's sad not the
best person in the world got such
[Music]
potential how long is a
day depends are my kids with me because
then it's too
long um but 24 hours is what they say 24
hours yeah it's 24 hours we could repeat
that every day without okay that's fine
but suppose you were to use the sun to
keep track of that how about the time it
takes the sun to get to its highest
point in the sky each day that ought to
be 24 hours because every day the sun
rises and it gets a highest point sky
and then it goes and it sets on the
other side all right right yeah that
ought to be 24 hours right but it's not
exactly
damn daylight savings time no
no there are some days where the
sun is
early at its highest point in the sky
relative to your clock and sometimes
it's late in the sky you're thinking
would cross the highest point in the sky
at 12 High Noon right high right that's
what they say sometimes it gets to high
noon before noon comes and sometimes it
gets to High Noon afternoon comes
sometimes the sun is fast and sometimes
the sun is slow now of course we're the
ones in motion around the Sun so I
shouldn't be sun centering those
sentences right but just for now that's
what I'll do and it could be by up to 15
minutes oh too fast or too slow relative
to your 24-hour day that's correct cool
all right what that means is you can't
really use the sun to tell you when noon
is because the Sun will be ahead of that
or behind it so if you're okay plus or
minus 15 minutes sure use the sun sun is
on CP time CP time don't go
there that's the sun son is like what
you talking about 15 minutes that's we
still good we're still on time we still
good still on time 15 minutes you you
really mad about 15 come on
man are you gonna tell people what CP
time is oh I'm I'm I don't want to but
I'm going to have to but yeah CP time
okay no how about this no don't do it
just make people go to the the Urban
Dictionary yeah go to the Urban
Dictionary and look up CP time if
you drew the Shadow the tip shadow of a
stick in the
ground every day at 12 noon the tip of
that shadow will Trace out a figure
eight on the ground over the 365 days
there'll be four
days where the Sun hits 12 noon at the
highest point in its Arc all the other
days of the year it's either before or
after that's the width of the eight
tells you how much before and how much
after 12 noon the sun arrived at that
point on the sky now this sounds really
obscure doesn't it but every single Sund
dial ever made has a figure eight on it
I was going to say but it it sounds
obscure now because we don't use the sun
to tell
but if you actually the to tell time and
you don't want to end up on CP suntime
then so you would use the figure eight
to adjust right the fact for the fact
that the sun was either slow or fast so
that you get the proper time accurate to
it in about a minute or two damn uh
actually I've done this experiment you
get it to within a minute that's a
properly oriented Sund dial when
corrected by this figure eight it's that
figure8 is called an analemma that is
the name of that Figure 8 uh and so that
so you might ask how come the sun is not
behaving how come the sun's not behaving
thank you Chuck because they got nothing
to do with the sun it has to do with the
fact that Earth's orbit around the sun
is not a perfect circle when we are
closer to the sun we are moving faster
in our orbit if we move faster in orbit
than when we're farthest from the Sun we
have to turn a little bit
extra to complete the sun's Journey from
noon to noon because we moved in our
orbit around the Sun so if we turn to
exactly the right same direction we're
not going to see the sun anymore we have
to keep turning right to compensate for
that and so these effects are not only
because we're in motion around the
Sun but because sometimes we're
traveling faster and sometimes we're
traveling slower those conspire to make
a figure
and that figure is called an anal if you
have old cartographic maps of the world
like old Globes look in the South
Pacific where they put you know the
legend for distance and the compass rows
and things in there you'll find an anma
typically now that is something I'm
gonna be honest had no never heard of
before just now that it never just
completely new and it but it makes
perfect sense and it's very important
because of course if you want to keep
time and by the way so if let's go back
to a perfectly circular orbit which we
don't have you would get this adjustment
anyway okay so the it takes 23 hours and
56 minutes for the Earth to rotate once
on its axis 56 minutes and 4 seconds to
rotate once well how come we a 24-hour
clock because in that time we orbited
the Earth and we have to turn four
minutes extra to then see the sun back
where it's supposed to be
so we say Earth rotates once in 24 hours
that is false that has never been true
Earth faces the Sun every 24 hours turns
back to the sun with a with an aligned
spot every 24 hours and that has to be
adjusted because sometimes we move
faster in our orbit and sometimes we
move slower all of that's going on
that's and you just wake up have
breakfast go to work and come home there
you go now you can have a true
appreciation for your digital clock
people
[Laughter]
cuz yes yes and uh and by the way most
ancient peoples knew about this because
what else are you do they didn't have
HBO you know Max at night what else are
you going to do at night you're gonna
look up right my god do they ever play
anything else on this channel
God on the sky channel the sky Channel
by the way December 21st in the northern
hemisphere first day of winter okay the
arc that the sun takes across the sky is
very low in fact it is the lowest Arc of
all arcs of every other day of the year
okay okay December 22nd the path is a
little higher in the sky and this
continues to June 21st with The Arc that
the sun takes across the sky is at its
highest okay all right this is part of
the reason like the primary reason why
it's warmer in the summer and colder in
the winter the sun is not very high and
it's not up for very long the Ancients
were very concerned about this the
ancient Pagan cultures very concerned
about this because the sun is everything
gives you warmth and and and your crops
and your and your you know your
agriculture so there's the sun getting a
lower and lower Arc in the sky so around
December 21st it stops getting lower the
sun stops soul s yes soul is the Sun s
is stops Armistice you stop the arms so
it doesn't stop in the sky the the
trajectory the daily trajectory across
the sky doesn't get lower but then they
weren't sure this it took a couple of
days to make sure and when you can say
hey it's on its way back up again that
would happened a few days later right
right gu what day that happened though
probably around I don't know the
Christmas you know nice nice Christmas
huge
celebrations so now CH Christianity
says we we don't want you worshiping
pagan gods we want you worshiping Jesus
that's right and so there was a swap of
there was an adjustment of where you
going to put the birth of Jesus passages
in the Bible if taken literally for what
they say would put it in the spring
right not in December but that but if
you want to get as many converts as you
can
you can't take away their holiday that's
cuz pagans know how to party pagans
party baby you can't stop you can't stop
the Pagan party you can't stop the party
no they got
the just drinking and it's amazing and
they're like coming along like no hey
guys by the way you can't worship this
anymore and uh there's this guy Jesus
you're going to have to kind of worship
him well does he drink well not really I
mean he can change water into wine but
he's not a big drinker we don't start
that's a start start yeah tell you what
tell you what here's a compromise how
about you guys keep your party and we'll
just celebrate him as a part of the
party we're good with that start the
fight there there there it was that's it
so that's basically the entire reason
for for the birth of Jesus be and
Christmas being December 25th y because
that's when you assure the son's Arc
returns in the sky so all of this is
going on in the 24-hour day in the
calendar and the 365 days of the year
that's all that's awes there's your
analemma for you anma baby anma did
write by you in the end I think all
right Chuck we got to run all right
there've been another start talk
explainer this one on the analemma Chuck
always good to have you always a
pleasure Neil the grass Tyson here your
personal astrophysicist keep looking
up
[Music]
a